.
Hello there. This is a internet video.
Slow Mo dogs. I don't have a dog, do you?
No, I don't.
Thankfully, I know someone who has a dog
that looks like a cat.
It's like a cat with a dog's head.
It's like a foxy cat dog thing.
Here's Jon Risinger and his dog.
Oh look at the puppy! Look at him puppy!
Look at the pup.
So soft.
So, we're going to film
the dog jumping for food
and also running through the field.
1, 2, 3.
Come on! Come on! Come on!
Successful video.
That is the bounciest dog
have ever seen in my life.
Bella, the kitten looking redemption dog
was very professional.
Weren't you?
Good job.
Yeah!
Had enough treats now.
.
You're a monster.
Who's a good girl? Hey,
come on, who's a good girl?